very much what like because with anybody
who's new to wrestling I'm sure you had
moments where
moves get botched or things don't go how
you got to keep going you got to keep
going but like do you feel like there
was a certain time or are you still
getting to the point where you feel like
you're hitting your stride in terms of
pulling up some of it because you pull
off some pretty crazy [ __ ] yeah I I have
a long way to go and I understand that
I'm getting more comfortable with the
the Reps I'm having I mean this year I
think I had under this year alone I
think I had under 20 matches this year
and when it comes to more than a five
minute match I think I had less than ten
and the majority of your favorites when
you say this year you mean 2023 or 2022
2022. okay I'll come back
your favorites probably have 10 matches
in like two months yeah not even that I
mean like for sure so for me not to have
these men this these many matches you
know this can can do a lot to you
mentally and physically because I'm not
used to getting these reps in and me
practicing Jade cargo can only get to
her biggest form live yeah and the more
people the more I'm into my character so
if we have like a dark taping with like
50 people I can't get into my character
the way I really want to get into my
character unless I see a sea of people
because I like that's why I do all my
heat outside because I like interacting
with the audience or I tell the audience
hey you idiots count to ten or five or
whatever I love interacting I love them
saying Oh you suck or this guy was like
you're 5'2 in person I was like get the
[ __ ] out of here and I like but I had to
stop because we're on TV and I gave her
um a choke slam and I literally was like
get the
can't say it and I went over to him and
I said something but um
I have a long way to go I'm like I said
your favorites have been in this game
for like five seven Brian told me he
didn't get comfortable until like seven
years wow so the fact that I'm on
national TV I'm pulling off moves and
like I'm doing all the transitions [ __ ]
for sure thank you and like to and the
funny thing is like I can do the big
moves they're easy like it's more so
like can my partner take the move or
like take this big bump but I can do all
these moves I was a power lifter for a
long time you were saying earlier before
we were on camera that you've lived
through like five lives I did so what
were you doing prior to being a
superstar wrestler on aew
um so I was a Collegiate basketball
player D1 Collegiate basketball player
went overseas for two years played
basketball over there
um Jacksonville University it's a D1
University we're uh we're overseas
um lahav in uh Normandy you know where
that France France okay it's yeah yeah
it's Pro uh Pro a so then I'm a child
psychologist I was a stay-at-home mom
and then I supported my spouse who
played baseball so I I did a couple
things probably this but also it made me
when I got back into well when I got the
opportunity to get into sports I didn't
want to let it go so so does your spouse
I want a trainer sorry you're still with
your spouse I am I when you were with
him he was in the league yes so now does
he get to kind of relax yeah guys kind
of switch positions yes well you're
running around and traveling and
Performing and yeah well he's a
stay-at-home dad but also we just um
brought into a softball team so we own
we're the fourth owners of a softball
team wow so there's only four uh teams
out in the league right now and it's
going to be in Dallas so that and then
he's the co-owner for the Lexington
Legends so right now who's your spouse
Brandon Phillips okay so he don't watch
me he played for the Reds the Braves and
won a ring with the Boston Red Sox he's
Rich yeah he's just relaxing right now
17 you know a bit but
he's at home taking care of our daughter
and I'm on the road right now and I
couldn't be more ecstatic because I love
it it's like fun and I don't need to do
it like I can go home sit on my ass and
make more money like pleasing my spouse
than like doing all this but I do it
because I love it yeah I love it